hello everyone I haven't streamed in a
while so I still have to check if
everything is okay with the setup but I
thought since we're pretty much all
staying at home
we might as well play some Blitz game
and play some blood games and maybe
agree to maybe a deal with tournament or
something we'll see how it goes
so just just let me know if if
everything is working properly and if
you feel like it feel free to drop a
challenge a multi-talented boy Sean
Clifford neater I'm 34 thumbs bill hello
guys I am pretty much have a have an
hour or two if you guys are interested
in some challenges I prefer non rated
maybe maybe three minutes three minutes
maybe maybe a bullet okay maybe even
five minute but so I can enjoy the chat
a bit more maybe maybe make the games
unrated in your challenges but yeah it
says here that the stream health is only
medium so I don't know if the stream is
fine but we'll see we'll see how it goes
okay let me just check some normal
challenges okay here we have a three
plus oh hey joram joram jim miner ah
meadow doesn't need a mask okay good
luck mister mister action one let's go
for some for some efore action it seems
that it seems that I could make the
board a bit larger there's a there's
some black on the edges right might have
to fix that or or am I just seeing
things
but we'll see okay all right what's my
leeches name leeches name is a good
motto okay let's stop b5 and continue
developing CC what happens to go for a
nice short Castle maybe maybe a king h1
and f4
yeah let's kick away that Bishop King
gate one maybe
okay and let's see if we can start
something here let's get the Queen in
Turgay maybe the Bishop to e3 bring the
rook into the game and use user time
wisely hey hello mr. Eden Hazard okay
he's doubling up on the C file which
which does make sense let's trade off
this dark square Bishop and get our look
into the game yeah makes sense let's
control the five a bit more and now now
we try something okay what do we go for
here okay
huh
doing very well on time
okay
still not not really doing anything yeah
sure just drop a challenge and I will
try to accept I prefer like three plus
zero instead of five plus zero just so
we can we can get more games in okay if
94c 2 is a bit vulnerable but then again
I can just capture and defend on C 2 and
then capture the pawn on e4 I guess well
we'll see what happens maybe now I want
to just shift my Bishop over to d3 so to
get rid of the weakness and then then do
something else with my Knights ah thank
you yeah it was a it was a pretty nice
podcast I really enjoyed it myself let's
control that f5 Square a bit more now
maybe even maybe even shift the rooks
here and maybe go g4 who knows maybe
maybe that's the way to go ok and that
makes sense definitely let's go for a
nice rook lift play a tap move yeah I
imagine I imagine that was supposed to
be a tall move yeah I thought about
doing the stream in a mask but but if I
did it in a mask you would hardly
understand me ok here he just gives me a
bit too much I don't think this there's
actually any point in doing this yeah
let's just go here push this maybe even
f5 now yeah or or we should just take
care of this here yeah I guess yeah f5
not no reason to go f5 just yet yeah
also also this could be an issue
huh a lot of interesting squares here
okay yeah he definitely got me there but
luckily we have captures and then we
just get our rook to safety let's say
check and then maybe maybe bring the
rook over to g3 we do lose this pawn but
at least we've we've saved our material
next I'll capture with the night maybe
c3 and it should be it should be good
weenies under attack let's go c3
strengthen this a bit let's pin the
night he's very long time so I don't
think he will be able to hold this yeah
let's go with let's unpin as well but
maybe here so Knight d5 doesn't come
with with any attack on the Queen okay
let's get this guy in here threatened
something here
he could go he could go there that's
true although does that do anything not
not much yeah okay he's definitely
trying trying something okay I I think I
played a bit too fast here since he's
extremely low on time but what are you
gonna do let's let's just back up
yeah I had I played a lot of suspicious
moves since I was extremely low on time
so I since he was extremely low on time
but maybe I should have tackled the
position a little better so
unfortunately I had to win this one on
time but you know that's always always a
thing in chess you you have to tend to
your time okay that's a four plus two
another three plus oh yeah the rook the
rook probably was free I I thought I
didn't need it yeah it's not a blunder
if you use it so so your opponent to
waste a lot of time I don't know if is
our good friend oh oh he played okay
let's go for some Scandinavian action
all right okay that's that's that's
shouldn't be an optimal move
yeah I did too think about making a
tournament what would you guys enjoy
maybe I may be a 2 plus so 3 plus so how
long one hour two hours or maybe I don't
know what did you guys have in mind yeah
three plus two is a bit too much three
plus two could last a good last
indefinitely and that's a bit too much
for the stream I'm trying to trying to
give everyone a chance for a game okay
this guy's really coming at me I have to
have to start developing something okay
if we get e five in I think we're doing
very well and he just he just Castle
kingside so we might even start
challenging this set up here okay it's
nice let's let's trade let's see what
happens with the night Oh with the
bishop that's uh that's nice
okay let's open a discovery here next
week or maybe he pushes g5 now could
also be it could also be a thing nope
okay let's open up some lines oh okay I
don't see I don't see the point but we
will we will definitely capture this
let's defend this deal here threaten
characters and and mate yeah seems it
seems like an idea okay so we capture
and that should be it
all right good game mister mister deso
deso rien we have a madness boy 21 two
plus one is best two plus one is the
best four for the tournament yeah did I
feel the earthquake yeah I felt that it
even woke me up but it wasn't as nearly
as severe as if it for example Zagreb
there wasn't really any damage here
since I'm some sixty kilometers from
Zagreb okay madness boys here we will
counter the ready with d5 that's that's
the way to do it and then if we can get
if Ivan no we can't but at least at
least we tried still we fight for e5 to
see what happens okay he allows it and
we go a5 and we should be okay here
so I've heard all right so develop here
maybe even consider a queenside castle
here huh since he didn't really try all
that much to prevent anything yeah let's
let's try it and see how it goes
I do have to be careful about about some
some sneaky ideas here but
other than that I don't think it's gonna
be a problem we'll see it's gonna be
interesting at least we have a okay now
I could be a bit discouraged about
castling queenside but maybe not maybe
not yeah I don't have the bishop pair
that's that's a shame I realize that
okay he's really coming for me on the on
the Queen side we're gonna have to make
some breathing room here okay
opening a lot of a lot of squares here
let's let's go here open up the D file
for my rook am i discouraged from
castling queenside or not well we'll see
let's firstly just first bring the rook
here and then we'll see okay that makes
sense I guess or or do I give it up for
for infiltrating with the rook yeah
let's let's give it up let's give it up
it's gonna be interesting
okay he captures here I character he
probably does a nice rook
oh yeah I missed that that's good that's
good although I think it would be even
better if you went for the pawn this way
this way I'm just up a pawn mm without
without I don't I don't think he has
well okay it's a double pawn here but
still let's let's guard this guy here
and now we get our rook into the game
and then we try to win the the knight
end game yeah mix makes sense do I even
want to capture that or or do we want to
complicate let's complicate complicating
seems like the way to go and we also
should get our look into
game makes sense that's a free pawn
that's a free pawn so I'm gonna go for
it and I'm also thinking about grabbing
this one okay he's going after this guy
here and also he does have this chair so
let's first let's first take it away
from there he's better on time yeah he
does have this chair but is it is it
really a good chair no then King here
and he loses either a knight or a rogue
so check is out of the question
yes complicate and they will blunder
that's that's the way to do it okay this
is another free pawn now if he attacks
me I go back and then we finally
activate the rook like this maybe or he
goes okay we're not giving you even that
yeah nope no we're not and now there's
the threat of just f5 winning material
so he has to do something about that yes
he does
yeah let's get the rock into the game
good things happen when you bring the
rook into the game okay I guess
let's just go here
okay we're going after this guy and now
now we start pushing our king is far
away okay we can even capture here I
guess threatening some nasty discoveries
he has to go somewhere with the king and
then I guess we start pushing okay makes
sense yeah let's let's start pushing or
maybe not right away
let's first consolidate a bit there's
always time to push and we are getting a
very long time at least I am so have to
do something about it if Knight d6
threatens mate that's good but I will
make some breathing room for my king
check we go here and now we continue
pushing finally nope still not giving up
that one sorry yeah you're welcome to
take that I will I will simply push my
past pawn and I will be very happy okay
that's a free rook we bring the Queen
into the game check win the light and
that's game okay that was that was fun
though that was very nice a very strong
mr. mr. madness boy 21 good game oh yeah
it's yeah I don't know maybe three plus
or five plus also I can read a bit more
chat positive bingo positive how are you
guys dealing with the with the lockdown
and having to stay inside all right
let's find a nice ace of it okay here's
an ace of it ease of it
ace of it with let me just fix the sound
a little bit not too much
alright everyone plays efore so I'm just
gonna go with the Scandinavian and this
is a free porn variation of the
Scandinavian
which is which can be played of course
nothing wrong with that he goes for some
rapid development and I have a pawn so
we just continue developing so I have to
play a bit boring here now as I do want
to want to enjoy my extra pawn but what
are you gonna do yeah still not
discouraged from castling queenside
although I could just Castle kingside
and play it safe we should we should try
to make it as interesting as possible
and it seems my internet is really
messing with me since I'm playing fairly
fast and I'm losing quite a lot of time
so not really not really sure what's
going on there okay let's move the Queen
I guess
yeah let's capture here go here and now
okay make sense we continue pushing
maybe get the knight into the game as
well
2:15 yeah okay yeah let's let's go ahead
with f5 I think that's the way to go
with a5 and we even yeah I think that's
the way to go
maybe a nice rook lift in there yeah
let's go here okay he wants he wants me
to push even further and that's exactly
what we'll do he grabs this one then he
just gives me he just gives me more
squares
for my rook which is what we definitely
want to do okay we grab some space here
it's a really funky position really
really funny huh
okay now he wants to trade Queens well I
don't think I'm down with trading Queens
any longer so we'll see what happens if
he pushes I don't really mind let's get
the knight into the game as well as many
pieces in front of the White King as
possible night here all right let's just
prevent that not really not really
enjoying that okay he decided to push
all the way let's get the rook into the
game as well okay he's not afraid of
anything that's that's what I like to
see that's what I like to see and now if
captures that's just weird
as we're gonna pick up the Queen with
check okay are there any threats here I
don't think so
is there is there a mate check in
captures check King has to do whatever
and that's mate unless I'm unless I'm
blind but it does it does appear like
its mate yeah not not much you can do
here yeah that's that's the good stuff
all right good game mister a civet yes
good phone chain I miss trapping the
rook with the Queen with rook to h4 did
I really oh yeah perhaps because yeah I
was constantly considering that he was
gonna play g3 and then I said yeah okay
that's no longer do I have a truck to h4
but I guess I guess it was there all
right good
stuff yeah yeah the thumbnail it was I
thought about I thought about a lot of
different thumbnails but seems like this
was the way to go as it kind of fits the
title which is which is the point as I
don't really stream a lot last time I
streamed was with during the celebration
of the 500 thousand subscribers
milestone and the prior to that I did
stream some games maybe I did stream
quite often maybe a year ago but then I
just stopped but yeah you know if if you
guys will be interested we could create
some tournaments okay it doesn't seem
like mr. cly Clyde daydrian is here so
we we abort I guess all right okay we
have a lot of challenges I will not be
able to accept all of them but I do hope
to accept most of them yes leave can you
play on leeches this is this is leeches
and all right we are here mr. Morra
alloy and finally we have something
other than efore so we're just gonna try
to try the nimzo-indian here let's see
how he goes for it let's go d5 and here
we go h6 yeah I capture and we go b5
yeah it's the the super sharp line yeah
still not ready for this let's go c6
yeah this is the the crazy line I guess
not sure if this is how it goes but it
is it is crazy
okay threatening on c3 he's not
interested in me capturing and c3 why is
that it's a bit weird huh Queen here I
guess
hey Thank You mr. a mr. salt and fresh
water for a further contribution really
appreciated man okay so the knight goes
there threatens something it's really
really a weird position really weird I
guess I guess I want to go c5 c5 seems
like a way to go
c5 we make room for the night and then
the knight gains access to d4 yeah
should be what's that he just decided to
give up a rook that's okay and he
resigns because of that okay I don't
know if that's how you play that line I
think it's some something like that but
it it's a really crazy stuff all right
good game mr. ahmad alloy what do we
have
okay mr. mr. I heard 395 last time I
screamed I got too drunk and forgot how
many games I played know that that never
happened I totally don't remember that
okay we obviously we have to go for
another Scandinavian people are enjoying
it
I'm hearing double sounds it's really
weird like I heard like I have to -
leeches tabs open what site am I using
I'm using leeches or should be invisible
from the title but yeah also sorry about
it it says that the stream health isn't
all that great but Manor net is just
ever since everyone started being at
home it just started being really bad
omaree thanks man for the congruent how
long will the stream last for well I
thought about it lasting for quite some
time but we'll see since my internet is
really terrible
yeah like now it just says I lost 30
seconds and I play to play the move
instantly so that's that's really bad
and one of the reasons why I also
decided to make a stream is to check
will my internet connection handle it as
everyone is now at home you know hogging
the the bandwidth so we'll have to see
okay didn't you yeah it's constantly
it's called it constantly says
reconnecting so yeah that's that's a
shame
yeah it says YouTube is not receiving
enough video to maintain smooth
streaming as such viewers will
experience buffering okay we will we
will tend to that alright let's just go
back we'll see maybe maybe it improves
yeah I know the stream is lagging it's
not it's not my fault well I will try to
do something about it
okay he moves the Queen that makes sense
let's castle here and prepare our efore
'if I've blast
hopefully hopefully that that does it
yeah that makes sense that makes a lot
of sense yeah that's that's even great
that's even great because he has this
check and then uhm I'm done for hmm yeah
I think I think I kind of messed up here
okay yeah definitely messed up here
let's go Queen before first as he does
have this ugly check when the when the
situation clears up he's gonna go for
that okay yeah makes sense makes sense
yeah really really blundered this one
hard
yeah and I can't I can't even try and
flag the good sir as my connectionist
he's terrible here okay that's that's a
good grab good grab
do I think nvl could beat Carlsen if he
won the candidates I don't know it's
hard to say really hard to say anyone of
course could could beat Carson and
anyone could lose against him in a match
what would happen we would we would have
to see but it would definitely be it
would definitely be a good match
I'm really looking terrible here and if
okay now I just blundered in my rook so
that's that's that that's oh that that
was good that was good
okay can't really allow him to grab the
bishop and he will try anything to grab
it I will however try a cheap move
just maybe Queen here followed by check
and picking up his queen it maybe if
he's not careful maybe it's gonna work
although I doubt it and he's much better
on time yeah that's what I thought it's
pretty pretty bad idea guarding with the
King but pretty much everything in this
game was a bad idea let's go check here
go here
huh
ah good stuff good stuff good stuff
alright seems my connection just
improved so I might actually be able to
win this but who knows
crazy stuff
[Music]
yeah I don't even see my connection is
lagging so hard that I don't even see
what's happening and I was able to win
on time but it was a it was a game not
to be not to be promoted so I don't
think I don't know if I can play since
its it's really just that my connection
is just terrible I will try to improve
it and let me just know let me just know
how how you would like the daily
tournament what what would you prefer
maybe three plus so five plus so 2 plus
so one maybe one hour lasting to our
lasting album so I thought maybe we
start doing the daily tournaments so
more people I guess a mister quad the
Ravenhill hello in the chat man and I
thought it'd be it'd be a good idea to
help us all all just chill in inside mr.
Joshua thanks for the contribution man
yeah that was there was a yeah I can't
it's the the stream health is just
terrible so I have to not be able to
stream anymore but let me know just
write write your preferred the time
format and yeah three plus oh okay and
we're gonna do it yeah it seems like the
stream is breaking up so I will have to
end